[Musique]
marguerite laborde et joseph carrère est
avec eux disparaîtra la civilisation des
siffleurs das s'héberger d'un village
des pyrénées qui avait inventé ou
maintenus jusqu'à nos jours un langage
sifflé il ne s'agit pas d'un code d'un
morceau d'un signal mais d'une vraie
langue ou plutôt de la modulation
sifflet du dialecte local
on connaît d'autres exemples de langue
sifflet de par le monde
aux canaries en turquie au mexique ces
langues ont toutes un point commun elles
existent dans les pays de montagne et
servent à se parler de part et d'autre
des vallées avec une portée de plusieurs
kilomètres les oiseaux sont comme vous
ils ont un langage de tous les jours et
vous avez l'impression voulait siffler
audace que vous faisiez comme les
oiseaux et les bas blancs
des fois je rappelle jusqu'à la guerre
de 14 on apprenait à siffler comme on
apprend à parler et la montagne
retentissaient des appels des bergers
d'as mais seul en europe ce village à
pratiquer une langue sifflé même les
plus proches voisins ne la comprenait
pas et c'est in extremis en 1959 que son
existence a été révélée au monde et
qu'elle a été étudié à la fonte des
neiges la station de gourette est en
transe sommeil
autrefois le printemps ramener ici les
troupeaux et les bergers siffleur mais
la vallée à tourner la page
définitivement langage
à siffler et n'est par nécessité cette
nécessité ne se fait plus sentir
il faut que ce ce langage qui fait sens
l'oubli est certes sans oublier qu'il a
existé
il faut malheureusement qu'il
disparaisse plutôt que de regarder
artificiellement dans du formol et
qu'ils soient repris par mauvais folk
lauriers alors qu'on conserve des bandes
sonores qu'on conserve des images
conserve des souvenirs
d'accord mais le récupérer pour le
récupérer comme ça en changer
là le côté originel je ne suis pas pour
[Musique]